[Music]
nope
[Applause]
capture the flag sweetheart
well glad that's over now we can get
back to civil rational conversations
devoid of any future felony assaults
right
right
a woman who is told if you're assaulted
please go to the authorities they will
handle it and then someone in a
privilege of power let's say a cop or an
attorney or whatever they ask the
question well what were you wearing that
night that permeates which is [ __ ]
it is so sorry and you think rape
culture is a [ __ ] can you just wait
we'll have a conversation afterwards i i
agree with your whole heart conversation
that needs to be had
serious rape has happened to me four or
five times and i'm sick and tired of
this [ __ ] debate men need to respect
women period so you should respect women
i'm sorry i am a woman so [ __ ] you if
you don't think so i don't really have
time for this and i don't have time for
my mistakes you're going to let me speak
because uh here's my truth i've been
reading four times i've known women that
have been raped multiple times
gruesomely and how dare you sit up here
and try to say that women aren't worth
respect [ __ ] you
i am a woman i just became a woman it's
just like are you [ __ ] kidding me
people don't respect me period and i'm
i'm already black so it's just like uh
yeah that already goes against me
anyways but still [ __ ] you
piece of living garbage ass dumpster
fire
trash gum on the bottom of my shoe oh my
god i wish i had a tissue for the blood
i would
might suggest it's your behavior not
because you're black or a woman i'm
sorry i'm sorry can i stop here can i
stop here can i stop here please
she has just made a statement about
being assaulted which is very vulnerable
and it's very scary to do
she just called me
i understand that gentleman just called
me a piece of [ __ ] so i'm saying that's
she
sorry my mistake there's accountability
between men oh absolutely a country
where guilty until proven incident
innocent yes we'd be rotting into jail
but i i know of
you
i know of a story just recently and i'm
sorry i can't come up with i can't say
the name of this individual
come on that's inappropriate sweetheart
[Music]
you feel better oh are you offended by
what i said no i just don't think it's
necessary aren't you just feeding into
it
you realize that's a violent crime
correct
you're fine
ah so because there's no damage done
it's fine okay
just recently that doesn't bother you
what if that were a man
because that's a woman
up back up back up don't get physical
back up back up man you're a gold digger
all you want is some money you don't
want no relationships do you know him no
exactly you don't know me all right
let's just back up if i was john cena i
bet you you're
if i was during the rock justin
nobody wants to [ __ ] here man you might
just want to get out here man leave me
the [ __ ] alone man don't touch me bro
get out of here leave me alone get out
here leave the women alone
you touch me i'ma crush you bro you're
going to curse me now i know which
person okay that's fine don't touch me
bro well i'm not gonna touch you but you
don't know witchcraft fool i understand
i'm gonna crush you and your firstborn
son you touch me okay all right well i
don't want that to happen from my
firstborn son but you know if you have
to you have to do what you have to do
just leave the women alone and go on
your merry way no i could do whatever i
wanted no yeah this is a miracle
actually you can't that's assault i
didn't touch the lady okay good so let's
keep it that way but she's uncomfortable
no being pretty violent no no no no i'm
out here doing the work of jesus christ
trying to defend these goddamn men out
here for these sorry ass females out
here
jesus christ call a lot of women gold
digging suckers diddy i didn't really
read about that and i didn't read about
that in march you want to read the bible
i got the problem with me go ahead and
read your bible and do your witchcraft
thanks man is everyone uh everyone good
you okay by the way just what we're
talking about you know i saw the big
wonder woman sign don't forget the
ladies which seem to have been forgotten
right now with the looting and black
lives matter and this stuff going on
this is a perfect example what you just
saw of an anti-rape culture i saw every
man around step in make sure that the
women were safe we was he was following
them he was chasing them
and i didn't see a bunch of guys going
oh yeah secretly we're on board with the
rape i saw every guy get protective and
want to keep the women safe i appreciate
you guys doing that um thank you and
it's not virtue signaling it's not white
knighting it's just making sure that
women don't get hit women don't get hurt
women don't get raped i think we're all
on board with that that's what men uh
instinctively want to do so
[Music]
is because this narrative is dangerous
and this narrative got garrett foster
murdered do you want to say that these
people out here saying black lives
matter are domestic terrorists you're
putting lives at risk so i will not talk
to you you know what you're doing david
foster was killed because he aimed an
ak-47 point blank in a car
no
the guy was right no but the police
reported
let's change the sign
let's change the sign we're going to
change a sign just for you we're going
to change the sign just for you about
garrett foster brothers
[Music]
i'm waiting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
and we'll be there
we do not entertain people who say if
boston was a terrorist
[Music]
did you guys love inbreeding let's go
bring your [ __ ] capitalist [ __ ]
elsewhere
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah
what do you want what do you want put a
mask on [ __ ] people are dying no
need to put masks on olivia
ollie what do you want bro
um
is that not a problem of course it's not
because i'm scary
take those glasses off
take those
y'all are the reason people are laughing
at this country
how hard is it to wear a mess for other
people
y'all are the reason people hate the usa
you're the reason we're the most
civilized nation
that doesn't have universal health care
how many people have to die herman cain
already died he died an avoidable death
to only
good
[Music]
have a nice day
yes he called me a racist he just walked
up to you and called you a racist yes he
called me a racist but let's take it
from the beginning
let me show you going up and seeing
what's going on
let's see let's move at least one camera
you guys like to come down and sit down
i just don't understand why one of your
little friends that look that boy over
there i think that right just came over
here which boy in the house
called me a racist for no reason this
guy and the white house
really yes he called me a racist he's
hiding though
he's just gone that's what i would like
to know he just walked up to you and
called you a racist yes he wasn't part
of his coverage conversation
okay well i'm sorry i have no idea
what's going on so were you there i was
there did garrett walk up and call him a
racist garrett's are not called into
racism yes he did
he called me a racist what happened is
this gentleman right here said that
he said you walked up and called him a
racist i said that sounds like you want
to hear what i said i said that sounds a
bit racist because you said everybody
over here is a lot what i've seen a lot
of white people i said race oh that is
yeah that's not that's not racist
people are white by the way he's black
did you know that that's not racist that
gentleman is dating effect oh okay the
people who are organizing this event are
white okay is that racist well it's just
odd that you would state it no it's not
because we were actually having
conversations i said i would love to
know you know how many people are
actually on both sides of the spectrum
sure republicans and the democrats over
here
oh so you don't want to know because i'm
going to go shopping we can sit down for
three minutes
and then he came over guy in the brown
or yellow guy i'm mexican brown mexican
brown guy that's how he that's how we
that's what we call people yellow you
call them yellow well you just said what
i'm drawing because you said white so i
thought color was the right way to do it
right no when you go what should i say
i'm sorry when you go take a test is
there a yellow box there's a white box
so white is okay but not yellow or brown
that's i mean y'all are the ones that
created these tests
i didn't create any tests what are you
talking about i mean when you go take a
test where you go take i want to
is that okay is that okay for me to say
it's not okay to say oh you're just a
yellow person i didn't say you're just a
yellow person okay i said one white guy
to a yellow or brown person yellow you
know whatever i said yeah one white guy
let's sit down and have a good
conversation one white guy to a yellow
or brown okay no
is that racist my point is
i was pointing out the fact that there
are a lot of people over here that are
organizing this event that are white
that is the fact
the man who spoke with you is black i
asked him i asked him
he's colombian he's black that man's
black you're a racist i also thank you
very much
i have to when i purchase a gun i have
to check caucasian as well as not latino
which kind of seems racist to me
would you grab a seat no not really okay
well i just because i noticed that you
were yelling and protesting i thought
maybe it's some opinions that you'd like
to voice
we actually have a lady there who
disagrees with me on probably nearly
everything but we're having a productive
discussion why do you think you can a
productive discussion where you make all
the questions and she has to unpack all
the questions no oh really would you
like to ask me questions really yeah
would you like to ask me questions you
can sit down right after maddie just
here's the question why are you a
mouthpiece for the alt light
what's the alt are you a gateway point
for
alt-right politics how so
oh how so how so dude i listen to
stephen all the time and i'm not all
right no you're a nazi remember
yeah you're he's one he's one of those
notorious black nazis
um
i don't i don't understand the question
uh let me assess you said you watch the
program i don't know where you line up
would you consider me all
right i mean would you consider me was
that is that implying i'm a racist i
don't would you consider anything i've
done racist no worry about it
so what what does that mean alt light i
don't understand the accusation it is it
means the
people like you ben shapiro uh
what's
because he's so jewish you think he's an
alt-right nazi
well considering that he supports a
genocidal apartheid state yes i would
say he is an isis genocide you mean like
eugenics like we're talking about here
abortion we went to a planned parenthood
margaret's thing no no no no no you know
what i'm talking about no i don't
oh really
oh do you mean that the jew supports
israel's right to exist and that's what
makes him an alt-right nazi right yeah
they're right
okay sure i'm sure a bunch of white
europeans coming into
a place i haven't been to in thousands
of years
it's like oh they they have the
birthright they're talking about jesus
you have the first right to discriminate
against palestinian jews christians
ethiopians armenians oh yeah oh right
yes yes
actually the state of israel
represent of the models of judea right
of course well no it's only addressing
your point that he's an alt light
alt-right nazi but palestinian muslims
have it better in israel than
palestinian muslims in palestine
why are you protesting
why are you protesting me and not
sitting do you want to come come on come
on come on
come on over and sit down condemning
israel of shooting
what's your name sir what's your name
sir no i'm not knocking myself
okay just no i'm not okay would you like
to come and sit down you have to give
your name not really
you should go hey listen here's one
thing
i don't like give out [ __ ] names all
you no no listen listen you don't have
to no hell thing you don't think about
your name but i do i do think that if
you're going to shout out accusations
and disrupt conversation that's
occurring that's productive dialogue i
don't i'm not i i do i'm here to shut
down your book you're here to shut me
down
hey maddie we'll be right back it's
going to be a little longer than i
anticipated but i promise we'll be right
back
you're here
you're here to shut down
conversation you believe that the right
thing to do is shut down people who
disagree with you people who support
violence
what
can you finish are you can you finish a
phrase did you just have a stroke listen
i don't mean to be insulting here but
just make a point speaking again
on this scale okay okay yes i'm a bit
nervous here how about you come how
about you come step down here we can
talk
i'm literally you're on a pedestal
compared to oh yes oh you're on the
pistol with you all the [ __ ] cameras
what
i support violent what
what gives you the right to shut down
here
for one this whole
pro-life when you're it's really about
denying health care to lower class women
that is what it's about that is what it
is about the funding planning paradigm
it's about the funding healthcare
for the people who most need it you have
no access
violence how is pro-life violence what
are you talking about oh i don't know i
don't follow you said violence you said
i support violent what
what do i support do i support i support
violence what
you are justifying your shutting down of
conversations we've had conversations
with plenty of people who disagree with
me they don't all act like you though
they act like they act more grown up oh
girl
and then yeah they act grown up so they
can be on your little show and make you
thousands of views and sell your little
t-shirts
maybe you're selling t-shirts would you
like one is that what you're saying oh
so you don't you don't have any
merchandise you know you don't have any
merchandise there's so many t-shirts
we're literally having no no no no no no
no i'm not seeing right here i'm not
saying right here okay oh so you don't
sell any merchandise right no it's like
unlike any other
this is all of a ploy by big merchandise
here's one thing let me ask you i think
it's very telling you said i am here to
shut i am not here to talk i am not here
to express my opinion this is what you
said i am here to shut down your
conversation oh yes the intolerant left
coming now yes yes that's exactly what's
happening here but is it not oh yes oh
yeah do you not see it as well
shut down
oh yes so intolerant to shut down the
conversation that represents the status
quo
of the liberal and conservative
establishment the whole reason you're
upset right
because on college campus expressing a
right-wing point of view is not status
quo brother oh yes it is yes it [ __ ]
is
all they do
i mean the republican club tbsa all
funded by the [ __ ] university can i
i i you can do whatever you want i just
i would never try and shut down your
speech here's what i would ask you
though if you could please let me finish
my dialogue with maddie
just don't shut down her speech
and if you want to come sit down you can
come sit down okay oh sure yeah okay is
that okay
okay all right i appreciate it
thank you very much thank you okay i
gotta go back to is matt hopefully
matty's still there
bruce or jesus christ depending on on
your uh ability to recognize yourself in
the mirror okay i'll go with bruce so
bruce it's actually jesus christ you'll
go with jesus christ i'll go with bruce
okay so bruce i don't believe that
president donald trump is not a racist
the reason the reason you should go with
god
is because i'm right here in front of
you and like you can actually learn
something from helping to save our
country and saving the world okay we
have to get all minds on you know all
hands on deck all minds on point
protect the truth jesus christ exactly
that's that's how that's the correct way
to pronounce my name jesus christ is the
correct way to pronounce my name you
stumbled upon it there you go
i'm i'm serious about that okay i don't
believe that uh i'm you you're me
there's only one me in all reality yeah
okay we'll go seriously there is we'll
go back to the jesus christ thing uh but
this is the reason we're here we have
the sign you know listen i don't buy it
that donald trump's a racist so you were
yelling earlier pretty upset why because
he he might not get he might not get
elected if people believe he's a racist
that's why you don't like that's not
what i don't believe that he's a racist
so again it feels uncomfortable you know
to feel like you're a racist because you
support donald trump if you if you sit
down is that why if you sit down the
onus is on you to change my mind that's
the whole idea
part of it part of changing your mind is
is is revealing your motives
why you don't want to see trump as a
racist you have motives and yeah you do
you definitely have motives you want to
get trump elected right you're a trump
supporter you want to see him get
elected you don't want people to think
he's a racist and because if they think
trump's a racist and you're you're a
trump supporter they're gonna see you as
a racist you don't like how that feels
so you're motivated to convince people
trump's not a racist whether he's a
racist or not you couldn't give a crap
but you want to convince everyone he's
not a racist
yeah so he gets elected
so everything you've just said is
incorrect uh no it's exactly correct
exactly accurate everything you've just
said is incorrect no it's exactly
correct it's exactly accurate and it's
in the realm of something that couldn't
let's assume you were whatever you're
saying is it not
you said you were going to sit down
but you can't call something i say
incorrect when it's actually correct
sure i can call it incorrect i'll
explain you why and i can say your your
statement of saying it was incorrect was
incorrect okay but anyway go ahead
you're a racist
you're a racist you're a tried and true
racist how am i a racist i think you're
a racist okay the fact that you've made
this your his own day i think you're
racist i think you're anti-jewish by
insulting uh uh people of the jewish
ethnicity claiming that you are jesus
christ no i think you're racist anybody
prove to me you're not a racist okay i
will prove to me you're not a racist
there is no proof you you can't prove
you're not a racist you can prove
yourself a racist though oh okay
you can't but i'm saying your motive is
that you're a racist if you you're
sitting down because you are racist
brown people in cages to be ever seen by
pedophiles uh you're a racist if if you
if you stand up and say i'm jesus christ
i am you you are me there's only one me
in all reality uh let's have the back of
life itself and not go extinct that
doesn't make you a racist no it doesn't
make you a hater of jews it makes you a
person saying hey i am you you are me
there's only one me and all in reality
you're racist let's have the back of
life itself let's save life from going
extinct honesty and truthful from the
lies of pride yeah that matters you
should be more honest about your racism
i am honest about who i am more honestly
i understand the racists that you are i
understand the racist that you i think
you're a racist you are a complete
racist you're right inside your head
you're a racist you are a racist i am
robber you are racist
to you bruce
bruce
because you're the only one insulting
anyone of color here are a nice brand
netherlands oh really thank you racist
you're good you're absolutely out of
your mind you didn't prove to us that
you're not a racist
but
hopefully you'll remember listen dummy
it's a thought exercise i'm here to
protect our country it's a thought
exercise
productive consciousness the me with an
[ __ ] listen
uh okay all right that's enough power
get up
yeah i'm going to stand right here
hey
take your hands off me louie
hey boys i'm going after my stuff you're
trying to let him take his stuff i even
raised my hand to you once once
what is
jesus christ ladies and gentlemen
that's straight from me jesus christ eat
my butt
this of course comes from the proverbs
hey where can we see pictures of you
without your shirt instagram i don't
know depends on if you have my keychain
to the cloud well i think you should
join mug club to see me without a shirt
and instagram to see him without a shirt
unless of course your shirt is one of
these that you got on our website that's
three things that's a non-sequitur but i
warn you about the hacks in advance
the nudes are probably me